throughout every country and every
culture there is always a cautionary
tale told to children a tale of a
monster or a demon that preys on those
who misbehave and today that tale is the
story of Lamia or Lamia the ancient
Greek equivalent to the boogeyman Lamia
was always seen as a monster though in
fact it's quite the opposite she was a
queen in the region of Libya and the
daughter of Poseidon she was loved and
admired by many including Zeus but like
many of the women as you Slavs Hera
became extremely jealous of the queen
and when Lamia and Zeus had children she
began to plot how she would remove the
Queen from the equation what Herod did
to Lamia does vary in some stories she
kidnapped and killed her children and
another she made Lamia kill her own
children
this punishment alone was on enough for
Hera and so she made it so Lamia could
never sleep cursing her to endlessly
walk the earth mourning for her lost
children that may be in driven mad
attempted to gouge out her own eyes but
she was unable to do so she had gone
from a respected queen with loving
children to a hermit like figure
ridiculed and shamed by the people that
once respected her so dearly when Zeus
all would have become with the woman
that he once loved he decided that he
will turn her into a monster a monster
that would be greatly feared and could
exact revenge on anyone who dared to
mock her he gave her the ability to
remove her own eyes which would allow
her to ease her pain and rest but in
turn this also made her more terrifying
she became known as the demon that would
devour children in the cover of night so
that others could feel the same pain
that she felt naturally this led to
terrified parents warning their children
of Lamia and thus a cautionary tale was
started there are some varying accounts
that claim was in fact Hera that turned
Lambie into a serpent and cursed her so
she was unable to close her eyes in this
variation it was once again Zeus that
took pity upon her giving her the
ability to remove her eyes and rest
many believe that she was somewhat of a
shapeshifter being able to transform
from a serpent into a beautiful woman
shed in her skin whenever she pleased a
talent that she would use to seduce and
devour men instead of children
Lemmy was also associated with magic and
witchcraft she had the gift of prophecy
a side effect of Harris curse brought in
her visions in her dreams whenever she
attempted to sleep many also saw her as
a minor sorceress brewing potions and
pacing enchantments on men so that her
presence didn't arouse suspicion
Zeus and Lamia children are an
interesting point of discussion the ones
that did survive went on to be quite
recognizable the most well-known of
those children was Scylla or Scylla as
you may know her the six headed sea
monster who killed hundreds if not
thousands of sailors and is definitely
one of the most iconic creatures of the
sea within Greek mythology Scylla had
only one sister the sea nymph
Sybil who had the gift of prophecy and
could predict anyone's death if they
were brave enough to ask
Zeus tsunami has lost surviving child
was Achilles who unlike his sisters
inherited his mother's Beauty which was
ultimately the source of his downfall as
he challenged Aphrodite to a beauty
contest one that he could never win when
he did eventually lose as a punishment
Aphrodite transformed him into an ugly
lipless shark and he would be referred
to as the lipless one the physical
depiction of Lamia is something that has
changed numerous times over the years
some Greek writers believe that when she
was cursed only her face changed
becoming contorted and more and more
disfigured the more people she killed
the traditional depictions were similar
to that of Medusa the upper body of a
woman and the lower body of a serpent
this form was believed to almost
mesmerize men her movement was graceful
and her scales were often described as
resembling precious gems
there are also depictions of Lamia as a
sea monster as she was the daughter of
Poseidon and the word Lamia was used in
ancient Greek to refer to a large shark
with one of her children even being
shown as a shock it isn't too
unreasonable to imagine that she may
have been seen as one herself preying on
children swimming in the ocean
a poet known as John Keats created an
extremely beautiful and alluring version
of Lamia one that is still used even to
this day she was a Gordian shape of
dazzling hue vermilion spotted golden
green and blue stripes like a zebra
freckled like a part I'd like a peacock
and all crimson barred and full of
silver moons that as she breathed
dissolves a brighter shun or interweave
there Luster's with the gloomier
tapestries so rainbow sided touched with
miseries
she seemed at once some penance lady elf
some demon mistress or the demons on
self her head or serpent but our
bittersweet
she had a woman's mouth with all its
pearls complete and for her eyes what
could such eyes do but weep and weep
that they were born so fair after Keats
his poem was published
Lamia began to be seen as an extremely
enchanting creature differend
drastically from her depiction as a
monster in traditional Greek mythology
humans been turned into animals and
monsters by the gods is something that
we see fairly often in Greek mythology
Lamia is quite an interesting figure
because her behavior and physical
depictions have changed so drastically
over the years she went from a respected
Queen to a monster known for devouring
children to even a seductress he
murdered men the term Lamia was also
applies to refer to a group of vampire
like demons who assumed the form of
young women Lorin men into their beds
and feeding on their flesh and blood
behind the illusions of their beautiful
exterior was a creature that had a long
Serpent's tail in place of legs
Lamia stories one that appears in the
ancient writings of both homer and Horus
and she had somewhat of a place amongst
ancient Greek people tales of Lamia
still even told to this day to frighten
children into good behavior I'd love to
hear your thoughts on Lamia if you had
previously heard of her did you imagine
her as a half human half serpent
creature that resembles Medusa in the
Gorgons did you picture her as something
else let me know in the comments below
so for those of you guys who missed last
night's announcement the channel
merchandise is now live over at
teespring
we've got t-shirts hoodies and
accessories and if you're a fan of
medusa and pegasus then i suggest you
check it out or leave a link in the
description and the comments for you
guys to click on but as always I've been
your host mythologies in fiction
explained